I started realizing I should just reach
out to every single brand that I want to
work with and so it garnered long-term
relationships with Brands where I was
getting six-month retainers or year
retainers wow I'm a very small Creator
still but I started making six figures
within the first year and a half you
know i' list out companies I dreamed of
working with all of a sudden within the
first year I was already talking with
CMOS of these companies and it was just
kind of an eye opener of like wow they
really care to hear my
thoughts this episode of the think media
podcast I get to sit down with Marissa
Hill AKA Shay TV who is representing
women sneaker heads and crushing it with
content we're going to be talking about
Trends we need to be paying attention to
the lessons she has learned when it
comes to content creation and really the
movement that she is building and some
insights for you to help you grow your
creator career so Marissa welcome to the
show thank you Sean for having me this
is a surreal moment for me before I
started my channel I was watching your
content so your huge inspiration is to
why I started my channel in the first
place so thank you for that well thank
you for your kind words and take us back
to when you started your channel what
the vision is and what kind of your
story is yeah so I started during Co and
I was out of my job I was modeling
full-time and of course everything shut
down no one was doing photo shoots so I
was of course shopping cuz that's
clearly what we do when we no money
right what can I buy so I was surfing
YouTube and I couldn't find any women
that I could relate to I just
consistently saw men with hairy ankles
which you can only see so much of that
when you're trying to figure out if I
can style this this way or that way I'm
like why are there only guy ankles out
there I just want a full look can
somebody show me the entire head to toe
look and so I sat down with myself I'm
like you know what I feel like I should
do some research stumbled upon your page
of course and a couple other just
inspirational YouTube channels to try
and understand like what it took to
really get a YouTube channel started I
literally started jumping on a bed in
sneakers and it was in a dark space I
had no lighting I was like man I don't
even think my audience can see the
sneakers in this video so it was really
just a rocky start I would say but I'm
just happy that I took the step to just
put something out there and you know at
one point in time I was like should I
take that video down it's so
embarrassing I love leaving it up
because it really shows where I've come
thus far but also I'm really just kind
of carving out a new niche in sneakers
which is what I was researching at the
time during Co I wanted to buy some you
know really expensive $500 shoes I
probably shouldn't have been looking at
but instead I'm glad I didn't buy those
those sneakers and I started to start a
YouTube channel instead that's amazing
and so what is the vision of shade TV so
so you know it's crazy cuz it's it's
really shifted a lot I think um when I
started the channel I really wanted to
do something different I didn't want to
do unboxings the same typical way that
other sneaker YouTubers were going about
their content uh so I kind of made a
list of goals and I think my top goal
was actually to speak at VidCon with
YouTube wow I wasn't expecting it to be
in this time frame range but um you know
i' list out companies I dreamed of
working with and even just doing
campaigns with so I wrote all those
things down and all of a sudden within
the first year I was already talking
with CMOS these companies and it was
just kind of an eye opener of like wow
they really care to hear my thoughts and
they really want to work with me
organically to where my content really
fits their purpose and their criteria of
you know what they're kind of packaging
and their marketing spend so it was
really just an interesting Journey for
me because I think I grew so so fast and
a sense where I was working with Brands
so early on and I thought that I had to
have maybe 100,000 subscribers before
anyone would care to talk to me but I
just started reaching out to people I'm
like I want to work with Nike I want to
reach out to Nike I want to work with
Lululemon I'm going to reach out to
Lululemon and uh of course some
responded some didn't uh but because of
my platform on YouTube I was able to
utilize all of that content to pitch to
them Concepts and ideas of how could
really integrate their brands into the
look and feel of of what I was already
creating and it seems like your newest
content you have like a pretty cool
Studio look wherever that's being filmed
where is that is that a home studio
that's actually my apartment that's my
second bedroom It's actually an office a
closet there's so many sneakers in this
room there's probably 300 shoes a kid
you not it's it smells like a shoe box
in there which is great if you love that
scent sure uh but yeah it's just a tiny
space it looks much bigger than it
actually is um
but yeah it's just my second bedroom in
my apartment what for you brought
modeling together with like more urban
sneaker culture so you know it's
interesting because in the modeling
world there's so many different types of
modeling I think people always think oh
magazine that's that's what modeling is
and it's actually not really what I call
the working model lifestyle uh but I
have done showroom for so long and
basically in showroom you work with
Buyers who come in and they meet with
ASI who are repping Brands and they
decide what they want to secure and buy
in their stores so it could be online
shops or like a Nordstrom or even Marcus
and they're always buying stuff based on
the trends and so I think because I'm
somebody who's like a sponge and I'm
always listening and trying to take in
information I was always just retaining
information on Trends and what looked
good and one of the things that I always
notice with these buyers is that they
always had really hype sneakers they
were always getting the best of the best
and of course styling it in a nice kind
of high fashioned way and I have a
athletic background so I played
volleyball in college that's definitely
been like a reason why I've always loved
and been passionate about sneakers
because it's comfy but also my Dad ran
track back in the 80s and he ran with
Carl Lewis flojo the great the joiny
cursors he was almost like the first
tester of a lot of track shoes which is
crazy to think like my dad is a key
reason as to why they created certain
products for you know that generation I
know if you could run in those shoes
anymore yeah but yeah so fast forward
with you know the modeling scene I think
that I just had such a nice in-depth
experience of understanding it from all
different angles so whether I'm behind
the camera shooting the product or if
I'm just learning and educating myself
from like the marketing and buying side
of things I love that and one of the
quotes about you is your representing
women sneaker heads someone said
somewhere that you're building the next
complex Network ESS entially and you
have a goal of being a platform as a
voice for other females what do you
think are the challenges Andor
opportunities for seeing more women
represented maybe not just in
Sneakerhead culture which would be
something that stands out but even being
here at VidCon or maybe in the Creator
economy overall yeah um you know what's
interesting is I always did wonder the
same as to why there aren't a lot of
women in the space and I think early on
I started to kind of understand why that
was and a lot of it is there's a lot of
degrading when it comes to women and
hype product because a lot of people
really want what you have and if they
can't get it you kind of become a
punching bag and they love to take it
out on you or you know you just get
comments that a lot of guys don't get
like who are you sleeping with you must
be sleeping with a manager you must be
married to some rich person who's buying
you all this product it has nothing to
do with the work ethic that you have
behind your content it just becomes you
know really signified as oh she must
doing be doing X in order to have this
type of content on the YouTube space so
for me you know with modeling it's such
a difficult Road already you get told no
a million times and people are very
straightforward with you cuz you get
booked off of your appearance and I mean
the things that you hear are crazy I
mean it's like one little tiny zit and
they're like what's that on your face
you're like oh I'm sorry I had a little
pimple pop up this morning but I promise
it'll be gone by the photo shoot so I
think I've had that tough skin already
built within me and so think because of
that it's allowed me to just look past
those comments and really just keep
pushing the Forefront for women to try
to be a part of the community and creete
content like me because we really do
need more of us out there to show that
same representation that hasn't really
been around at all you know and it's
always weird cuz I feel like I am the
first one really embarking on this path
and it's strange because I don't know
like exactly the direction I'm going in
but to your complex point I think a lot
of people are coming to me as a media
Source almost as if you know I'm that
One-Stop shop where they can find
information from a woman's perspective
so a lot of media Outlets unfortunately
that do cover sneaker content it's all
men it's very hard to find women and
specifically women who are just wearing
the products and sometimes you know you
will get women who over sexualize
sneakers so it's like bikis and sneakers
and that's a different subgroup but also
you know what I always tell women is if
you really want to be in this Niche and
say you're up on stage and people are
asking you questions about sneakers make
sure you know what you're talking about
because you're representing all of us
and it's so important that you know when
I'm up on stage and I'm talking about
sneakers I know what it is I'm saying
because I know that I'm standing up for
all of us when it comes down to it and
it does make a difference and I don't
want to be stereotyped is that
uneducated girl who hasn't earned her
seat at the table doesn't have enough
sneakers or the right sneakers to be in
this Niche so you know I've been really
just pushing those boundaries and
setting an example for these other women
who maybe have felt like they never had
a community that they could belong to I
want to hold my arms wide open for them
and say that you know I'm the support
system I'm this platform where you can
find education information on how to buy
sneakers how to style sneakers whatever
it is I want to be that place for those
women to know that they can go and feel
safe your vision is inspiring and I
would love to uh learn from lessons
maybe you've seen from your content it's
also really cool to hear that you're
being viewed as a media company it makes
sense but you're still on the rise and
from a second bedroom you're a media
company from a second bedroom you're
you're the new wave and I think that's
so inspiring being in the crater economy
of what's possible to launch big things
on a small budget or launch big things
uh with small resources and so uh really
inspiring I looked up your top videos
and I'm curious you know now that you've
had some videos cracked your biggest One
cracked what 300,000 yeah um and it was
on Funko Pops what any lessons you
learned from that video so I had so much
fun doing Funko Pops um was that a
previous Niche so actually it was
integrated with sneakers um I was
working with funko's team and they would
send me funkos and I would actually
coordinate them with my sneakers
and it was really fun like I had a
friend doing voiceover so there was one
where I was doing Deadpool and he was
voicing it over and we would tie little
string to the Funko pops and have Batman
like fly across my face here and there
it's funny cuz I feel like sneakers
relate to so many different things in
pop culture and Funko approached me and
they're like hey like we would love to
send you Funko Pops we see that you have
them on your back shelves uh so they
started sending me hundreds of them and
in my space I'm like oh my God I got to
pick what am I going to collect am I
going to collect sneakers am I going to
do Funko Pops Godzilla versus Kong was
coming out and I was the very first
person to have these massive Funko Pops
they were huge and of course everybody
was super stoked they had the best
commercial I remember when it released
like the trailer was insane I was like
oh my God this is going to be big time
and of course those Funko Pops arrived I
had no idea I was going to have them and
you know with me when it comes to time
frame of putting out content for
sneakers and even Funko Pop releases
it's very important to get it out as
soon as possible yeah can't wait timing
is everything so that is something I
definitely learned through my journey is
like you can't just sit on content even
though it's done and you want to be
patient and think oh well I've already
posted two videos today it's not about
that in my world it's all about kind of
being the first at some point in time
because that will change your you know
viewership on that specific video if
it's delayed or late yeah speed matters
and especially with trending things and
so good lesson to to hustle to and not
sit on content also you've got multiple
videos really on the Yeezy Runners and
the Yeezy slides those did very well
yeezy's a massive Force went through a
ton of drama recently obviously what
completely kicked out of Adidas now back
in yeah um what do you think as kind of
a niche Sneakerhead question do you
think that yez will rise back to what it
once was do you think it'll be bigger do
you think it's losing its momentum even
now that they're back on Adidas what's
interesting so my highest view video I
think is on the slides what you're
referring to and I was the first person
really to care about those nobody wanted
them and I was like I love them great
price point I'm like I can for this easy
to slip on super comfy people thought I
was crazy but I was the first person in
my Niche to really tap into that and
sizing was way off and so I sat down
with myself and I'm like I think I need
to start doing sizing videos because
this is not the right sizing and luckily
I bought so many different size ranges
so I could test them out but that video
did so well because it helped people
essentially understand before they were
trying to go after the slide itself what
size range would work best for them
because as most people know in sneakers
if you mess up on your size you can't be
like hey easy can I get another pair the
size didn't work out they'll laugh at
you and be like no we'll take your pair
but you're not getting another one
there's no way so I think as far as the
brand goes
there's definitely been some rocky
moments and I think something that's
really challenging in my Niche is
there's a lot of creators that Focus
primarily on EES and so that's really
taken a huge huge fall in their growth
because the fact that they took such a
huge long period away from actually
having any set releases going out and
for me I've always just tailored to
multiple Brands having a variety of them
so that I'm not you know really cornered
into focusing on on just Yeezy alone so
I think as far as Yeezy itself I think
that Kanye will probably most likely be
doing some crazy stuff but not with
Adidas I think that they'll finish out
the product that they've actually made
since all the factories have already
produced millions and millions and
millions of product and of course they
don't want to sit on that and so they're
donating some of the profits they're
made to Charities uh but I think once
all of that product has been you know
sent out mailed out to anyone who's gone
after it that will probably be the end
of the production line for easy and
Adidas that was another good nugget you
shared there for any content creator you
might have the opportunity to rise a
shooting star but if that star goes into
some drama or stops shining as bright
your channel could become very
vulnerable if it's completely built on
Yeezys and something happens or they're
no longer trending then your your
channel was probably too niched and it
do you could pivot but in your case
you're not niching down that
specifically your channel is about the
culture overall from your perspective so
that gives you longevity have you been
doing vertical
video yes shorts do you uh what have you
seen any success shorts you're doing
other platforms multiplatform so I
always say it's it's like an ecosystem
and the ecosystem is always what makes
me so successful in comparison to just
being dominantly on one platform cuz
there's different audiences everywhere
especially for sneakers I'm banned on so
many Reddit threads let me tell you my
god well a supreme Reddit thrund banned
permanently for life because um they
don't want to see
low excuse my language quality content
on their Reddit thread page AKA they
don't want to see a woman in Supreme
geez um so I've been banned on actually
a ton of Reddit threads but I'm still
active on a ton of of them and those
viewers are so engaged because they're
going there they really want to dig into
why they should invest in a sneaker and
be walking around New York every day I
meet a redditor I'm like of all the
platforms you follow me on Reddit like
are you sure like yeah yeah I read red
threads all the time like okay that's
cool um but you know per platform it's
so different but I always make sure that
I'm creating content all around so that
even if it's on Twitter you know I know
my still imag is on there and Pinterest
will do well and now I'm starting to do
more video on those platforms also but I
do shoot both ways I chop up videos
sometimes I I completely just shoot
separate as well but of course that's
more time consuming I love that VidCon
uh is where we're at here in Anaheim and
you just spoke on a panel focusing on
maximizing creators earning potential so
what were some of the things that you
shared on there and what are your tips
for people that are trying to earn money
in the Creator economy and what's kind
of the business model that you have
going with at least when it comes to
your shade TV so it's interesting um I
think there were amazing panelists and
we differed in so many ways I think that
what separated me from the rest of them
is I'm a very small Creator still but I
started making six figures within the
first year and a half which is insane I
never would have dreamed that and you
know for me I utilize every tool
on YouTube that I can and I think that
their platform really does set you up
for Success if you take advantage of
what's being offered to you and early on
you know when I was looking back at the
video where I didn't have lights and
things like that I would kind of joke
about it and some of my lives I always
Premiere every video by the way I have
like 2,000 videos I think I posted I
premiered every single one of those
videos and it's so important because
that is where I get so much funding all
of my viewers lately have been buying
each other memberships when they're on
my lives even if they don't know
somebody who's hopping in in the comment
section it'll be like you know Rudy just
bought so and so 20 different
memberships and what ends up happening
with that which is crazy is like people
who maybe weren't consistent regular on
my premieres all of a sudden are
constantly there because somebody bought
them a membership and also just saying
if maybe my lighting's bad or I wish I
could have this or that I'm so
transparent with my audience that
they're like hey shade like here's 20
bucks put it towards this and I'm always
I think open about saying like
everything that you invest in my channel
goes back to the channel because I
always want to up my game on the content
that I'm presenting to them and so I
think being able to do Super Chat
getting stickers uh memberships is
another thing that you know is super
important when it comes to early content
so one of the things I'm rolling out
this year is Early Access to content for
sneakers that you're not going to find
anywhere and not that I'm gonna keep it
from the rest of my community who aren't
members it will get released them as
well it'll be the same exact content but
just my members will get early access to
that yeah uh but you know I've just
really been having fun with the platform
and it's been a fun Journey just seeing
what my members are really invested and
interested in using and even having a
nice Discord where it's kind of therapy
session for them to say hey mariss I
took an L day this is rough day for me
could really use a w on the sneaker and
you know I'm I'm there to be that
support system for them um but you even
outside the platform I make so much more
money doing so many other things I mean
I got my first sponsor at 3000 it was a
tiny company and I knew that they were
tiny but I knew that I could grow with
them and I believed in them and it was
crazy I was like wow how how am I
getting sponsorship at 3,000 I'll take
it you know I'll put your name
everywhere whatever section you want you
got it it's going to be there uh and
then I started realizing I should just
reach out to every single brand that I
want to work with and do pitch decks
media kits you know I really fine-tuned
my Media Kit to where it was perfect in
a sense where it was really
representative me but I wanted to make
sure that in comparison to other
creators it was going to be the best and
I was going to be able to Market myself
and Pitch myself in 30 minutes or less
and get that second phone call and so it
garnered long-term relationships with
Brands where I was getting six-month
retainers or year retainers wow and um
that was something I never thought I
could do through the YouTube platform
and I think a combination of that with
all the monetization tools that they
allow you to use it's just really made
this such an amazing experience to where
I feel like I can now just solely make a
living off of you know social media
that's amazing and so if I recap a
little bit tell me if I missed anything
um you've got YouTube ad Revenue coming
in you premere your videos which allows
people to gift memberships or do super
thanks or super chat um while those
videos are premiering you also are doing
brand sponsor
sponsorships and then Channel
memberships through YouTube is a
community you're trying to build up is
everything I just mentioned what equals
six figures or is there any other income
streams uh so I would also say affiliate
links are going to be huge coming up
just because of the new way that uh
YouTube is allowing it to be visually
present throughout your video so if I'm
talking about a specific sneaker what's
amazing is now they have these shelves
where you can actually go directly to
the product it doesn't have to take you
somewhere else it just goes directly
there and typically I just would have
links in my description box but now I've
noticed this uptick of people just going
directly to those photos clicking on you
know that product so affiliate links are
huge for me uh and initially too what's
great about YouTube doing this is I
would have to go individually to Brands
and bargain my affiliate you know rates
that I wanted because I didn't want the
lowest tier and this now allows you to
not even have to worry or stress about
that it's already there for you and
right now it's around like 20% Which is
insane wow for physical products yeah
for physical products so say somebody
buys a sneaker from Sachs that's 20%
back in your pocket which is crazy I
mean imagine how many views you'd have
to get to get that same amount of money
do you know how it's going to work so
does YouTube having it integrated in the
Shelf does it have to be already be it's
through YouTube them connected to the
vendor mhm and YouTube must get it cut
as well yeah they're definitely getting
a cut and I also don't know how long
it's going to stay at that high of a
rate cuz that's I mean I've never seen
20% you know my typical I do get 20% for
certain brands but it's very rare that
you see that on a regular for the brands
that they've been pushing on their space
yeah YouTube shopping is making a lot of
announcements this year at VidCon so
they've been rolling out some amazing
new features and so if you are all the
way back on maybe your Yeezy slide video
though you'd put your own affiliate
links in the description oh yeah you go
to multiple different stores how for you
do you pick out which ones I mean for
hype product it can be difficult because
the problem is is it sells out so fast
but one of the things is they have
cookies built in so say even if they use
my link the products not available for a
different launch yeah and they or they
decide to just buy a sweatshirt and a
pair of socks you're still making money
from that because the cookies captures
it and say you're the last person that
they clicked on you're going to get the
credit for that yeah which is amazing so
without YouTube shopping Affiliates has
been part of your journey the whole time
Affiliates has been a part of my journey
I would say even just sponsored videos
on YouTube I do a few of those dedicated
you know long form videos typically a
few times a month depending on what
brands and I always package it in where
it can be tied into other platforms as
well so you know it's kind of like a
buffet sale that I offer to Brands where
you can kind of pick and choose what
works and what fits for you because
sometimes you know Brands want me to
travel with them I went even for
instance with YouTube to Coachella last
year I was at Coachella with Adidas um
Adidas blew me to complex con for their
Prada Adidas sneaker drop they wanted
visual content of me just interacting
with people at the actual event but also
I do moderating as well so I did a panel
for the US Open for Tory Burch and then
I did another panel with Coco golf in
the city for Foot Locker and you know
those are just other streams and ways to
make income that I think sometimes
people are so small-minded and they
think oh I I only have the platform to
utilize you know what I'm doing in my
Niche but if you think outside the box
there's so many ways you can incorporate
what you're already doing in your topic
into other directions for the companies
and all the time I'm asking them well
what's what's your year plan you know
what are the projects you're working on
I try and figure out well how can I fit
into that plan as we land the plane if a
good friend comes to you or a family
member even somebody you care deeply
about and they're like saying Marissa
I'm thinking about launching a YouTube
channel but I just look around and
there's so much competition is it too
late to start YouTube right now and do
you have any advice for me it's never
too late and I always you know it's
funny because I always say that there's
a lot of excus makers out there and
you'll literally list 20,000 excuses
before you decide to take that jump and
so being an athlete I mean I'm such a
competitor and I've always wanted to be
the best in everything that I've done
and I'm fortunate enough to have those
skills that I can now really transition
and apply to what I'm doing in the
YouTube realm of things but I think it
doesn't matter what Niche even if it's
saturated if you are the best at what
you do that's what matters at the end of
the day it's it's almost like companies
in that I guess perspective it's like oh
this person may have been the first the
Post-it note but what if somebody came
along 10 years later and they created
even better Post-It note now Post-it
notes out so I always think of it that
perspective where it's never too late to
be the best in the niche that you're in
I just so happen to find a niche where
it really needed a female voice and so I
think even if it is something is
saturated as makeup like I talk to
people in my industry all the time when
I'm at work it's like a little campside
fire chat everybody's around me the
creative director comes over just like
what are you guys doing over here and
it's like Mar is giving us a YouTube
talk and um you know I'm always telling
them if you're struggling to make money
on a day-to-day basis and you want
something that you can really truly just
have total control over you don't need
an agent to help you out it's all within
your control think outside the box like
what do you good at in makeup is it
maybe you're somebody who only does
bright colors you know like I have a
friend who does incredible unicorn
colored hair if she started a YouTube
channel she would go viral I mean I
don't know anybody else who does hair
like her it's insane but they don't even
know sometimes when to take that step
because it seems like it's so much work
but at the end of the day I look back
again at my first post I'm like was crap
but I needed to do that I love it such
great advice and uh for those that want
to connect with you you have multiple
accounts so shout them out of course
we'll link up sometimes people don't
like my my face they want to see only
sneakers um and so we'll link these up
in the show notes but go through the
list uh the call out of all your stuff
uh yeah so Shay TV 47 is my Instagram
and my YouTube page that's where you can
find pretty much Street Wear and sneaker
related content and then I also have
Marissa eill which if you care to see
modeling photos um I like to post up
there for that content and then Shay
tv247 for Twitter Reddit so grateful for
you thank you for adding so much value
today thank you so much for having me
and think media podcast subscribe if
you're not subscribed definitely share
this episode out with somebody if you're
on YouTube smash like let us know you
thought if you're on audio rate and
review and we will see you in a future
episode